Hmm, I thought the only toppings I could use were green onions and perilla,
but maybe they'll eat this before the noodles get stretched.
I grated the potatoes and added them. Thanks to that, the potatoes have a good thickness.
Also, potatoes contain a lot of glutamic acid.
Because it's grated, the small chunks of potato are mixed in slightly and accentuate the texture.
The
thick
noodles that are entwined with the thick soup enhance the satisfaction with the contrasting texture.
The texture and sweetness are all condensed into a bowl, so
it's the finest potato side
.
It's
Jin-kun's furniture,
ah ah ah
, I passed the Air Force